[Laughter]
i don't know the characters
you ever met this guy oh i'm the dumb
one you can't argue there's something
about me you have no idea what you're
saying gang gang
buzz bug
sure you got that mcdonald's uh i was
just gonna mention it yeah you uh doing
a sh you're doing a shift at burger king
after it's gonna be quicker though to do
that than go somewhere else so i didn't
make sense uh i like the outfit today
you look like uh you you're the the
cruise ship uh
captain yeah you look like a cruise ship
captain for trump's express
i'm americana baby
they're kinda
just that hat
you don't have a good hat head coming in
hot this hat is good no dude it's like a
yarmulke it's so your head is so oh wow
i don't see that
look good you're just not used to it bro
change is good
and i'm feeling good and i look good
don't push me you know you can get this
[ __ ] at chris
all right here it is
there we go what are you gonna do you
brought it up you need to start selling
this on christmas i do i know you're
right are those wings on the hat
uh these are just it's americana baby
dude this is like yeah it's like a
[ __ ] navel i don't know man what's
going on with you today what are you
talking about dude you're in a mood
today bro i'm defending myself you guys
came in so high no you're just there's
like vibe about you today there's
something going on what is it i got it
right i gotta be honest right there's
some kind of is it the hat there's a
thing that's up to you baby did you wake
up a little weird today yeah oh there's
a tea do you feel like uh just i don't
know
you know what i feel like storming the
capitol you know what it actually maybe
is i had to wake up at
6 00 a.m kristen and calvin are going to
their uh kristen's friends in saint
louis and i i had to wake up poor calvin
and calvin's not there but they're going
to meet me in dallas uh
on on oh gotcha on thursday so but it
was it sucked because i was like i was
like really bummed that i was going to
fly with them you know
and uh so i knew something so maybe it's
that and then i went back to sleep for a
few hours and then maybe [ __ ] up your
sleep cycle your rem sleep maybe maybe
maybe it's that but um yeah so i don't
like like being at home alone i don't
like being alone there see i knew i
thank you it was off you're off you're
macaulay culkin watch though i'm gonna
[ __ ] kill it this episode okay yeah
but you're getting that weird you know
but speaking home alone
speaking of killing it i'm gonna be in
la jolla here we go
september 9th through the 11th i'll be
in la jolla just you know and now and
you're like happy about it yeah
improv 15th through the 17th i'm going
to the skankfest i don't know why but i
am 14 through the 16th skank it up doug
and caloosa casino that's october 28th i
see i haven't done that a while
that's a fun one my date's out oh that's
why you should ask and i will wear the
hat in appleton wisconsin september 8th
through the 10th then after that i will
be in ontario california ontario improv
then i close september in boston boston
laugh boston is september 29th october
1st yeah so then i guess i'll be in
dallas tomorrow and wichita the next day
and then atlanta and i have atlanta and
dc coming up atlanta just sold out dc
wait all the same tour like
no i'm gonna i'm gonna do
dallas and wichita then fly back for a
week and a half and then go to do uh
atlanta and then washington dc and then
savannah georgia and then like this you
know do you stay out when you do that
kind of stuff no i come back that's what
i'm saying every time right yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah people that stay acting
like where guns and roses are right
well i don't know
well you're just like and then i'm in
atlanta and d.c and i shoot on over to
europe back dude i know but don't say
shoot on over because then i figured it
was did i say shoot on over i felt like
you did all right well i'll have to go
back and look somebody might have to
scrub back and look but
then i guess i'll be in dallas tomorrow
and wichita the next day and then
atlanta and i have atlanta and dc coming
up atlanta just sold out
yeah dude
anyway so i'm doing the [ __ ] and i'm
[ __ ] you know i can't wait to get out
there bro i'm not buying it yeah you
think i don't want to get out there
you're good too i won't be alone
i won't be alone
hey chris hold up chris you acting right
now yeah you pretend to be happy my god
yeah rips this mask off
yeah good dude i i uh i'm going i'm
bringing calvin i told you they're
meeting me in dallas and i heard you and
then um have you brought calvin like on
on
on stage on something big phoenix yeah
oh wow how was that great picture
i can't even think about it without like
just like i mean it was so great it was
so special this is what it is what his
wife and kid are like he feels their
absence i do that's what it is
i'll come over we're here for you hey
thank you hey we're here hey i'll bring
my sleeping bag am i but we got a chin
here
i'll bring my sleeping bag but what
about like
take one of my kids let's just barbecue
let's go to his place we'll barbecue i
don't know i don't know if i ever used
to be like that you know but like now i
feel like i i literally feel like my
family is so my oh
when i'm with you when they're not there
it's like uh what did i used to do yeah
i mean i have no idea what i did before
kids no clue
i have no time i mean yeah i don't know
i don't but like
is that so it's normal yeah
because i talk to people that are like
yo i can't wait to get away from the
[ __ ] face they don't mean that you
don't think they do no they don't mean
it this is something you say you think
uh some do though i think if you're like
strict nine to five schedule and they're
with fam then well you know with the
boys going to vegas to play golf some
gay [ __ ] but with us it's like with us
it's like you know we stand up we're out
at night so it's just different yeah
tiger woods just went like this
what what's the gay [ __ ]
i'm just saying you know you know what
the guys do happy hours and [ __ ]
people no i i feel like that i think
people i think that people say that they
just like are saying like they they
they're looking forward to doing this
you know thing that they haven't done in
a while but for the most part i think
people that are family people like i
just got married and i'm always thinking
about like what i want to do with rachel
and all that kind of stuff yeah so i get
you all right all right kyrie from rhode
island here again and i got a king just
thinking for you guys grateful dead team
we're talking older television shows
none of that cuda [ __ ] none of that
those new shows no no stranger things
none of that i'm talking things that are
like 10 15 years old tutors now we
talked things up that alex don't say
tutorials and uh the reason i'm
wondering is because when you watch them
you really can't like talk to anybody
about them the way you could if you were
watching something that's trending on
netflix or something right
um i do anyway though that's it yeah
buzz buzz
we're soaring i can't i ca i watched it
i watched a tutor so obviously he
listens to my podcast because i've
talked about it yeah um i watch the
tutors
i'm into the tutors and it's on your
podcast you're mentioning that you're
watching the tutors because of
my recommendation she did recommend it
didn't you i forgot i forgot of course
you forgot about it because when you're
in congratulations it's just like
okay
me me me me
well yeah that's what i guess thank
[ __ ] christ dude but there's there's
certain shows you can still kind of talk
about you can't get into details because
it's so long ago yeah like you can
reference some like mage or [ __ ] like
the last episode of the sopranos or
[ __ ]
um
or like say if you're going old school
like say by the bell like when jesse
took too many caffeine pills big moment
yeah i saw a [ __ ] i went i was in uh
i went to my cousin's wedding and we
were at um we were in seattle we had an
airbnb me my mommy my daddy and uh
kristen and calvin and do and a few and
a few spiders and um and dude there was
uh we watched golden girls and friends
and uh seinfeld we had a [ __ ] blast
golden girls is one of the funniest
sitcoms ever might be the best sitcom
ever
where i i you know what it's mount
rushmore for sure yeah yeah i mean if
someone said seinfeld okay but bro
golden girls man
thank you for being a friend
[Applause]
traveling
that's not that's a remake of this song
oh well this is better
oh we're balcony from terrific strangers
perfect strangers
no perfect strangers nobody's pregnant
it was all right
[Applause]
do you know what i hate doing most after
a party trying to find your underwear in
the big
pile you're being a [ __ ] hater yeah
god i'm so much younger than you guys
here we go this is strictly off the
record but derek's nearly five years
younger than i am
i like that one she's a [ __ ] all the
time then rod blanche
[Applause]
yeah the okay if we were go to girls
[Laughter]
i'm clearly
[Laughter]
i don't know the
and all that uh what other shows did you
[ __ ] with that i would know of uh
jefferson's
jefferson's play andrew good times
no one watched tji friday we're talking
step by step full house
i was watching
domestic violence first of all there's
no better theme songs than good times in
the jefferson thing yeah cause he's he's
clearly betty white because she was the
dumb one oh wow you know what i mean
yeah we actually are great golden girls
oh cool it's darn tale
or like a cute version of mark right we
have some
a younger version mark's still like cute
he cuts all his stupid hair off oh you
don't like the hair the the silver log
silver surfer yeah looking like the
freaking
let me see looking for the freaking lion
from a wizard of oz yeah
original
you're the hater
that's the cute version of mark yeah
this is the cute version of mark
and he's ugly
i was gonna say
yeah yeah
this is you upgraded right we've got
some great submissions today some crazy
characters and a couple we're gonna zoom
in live who have like insane stories
that they want help with let's take a
little break from the boys chris is
taking a booper so i'm here to run the
ad for you guys listen college football
is back fam it's my favorite time of the
year it's time to enjoy the tradition
all right it's fun and listen you want
to have some real fun make some money
while you're watching college football
this year with my friends at draftking
sportsbook it's time to celebrate the
best time of the year right now new
customers can make just five dollars on
any team and get 200 in free bets
instantly
instantly
win or lose that's not enough action for
you you can also place the same game
parlay for a shot at even bigger payout
just combine multiple bets into one like
which team will get the win which team
will score first and so much more i'm
all about usc this year i love what
they're doing the new coaches they're
paying players we're gonna ball out we
get the most money all right wish my
buffalos were gonna be better but what
can you do draftkings is safe secure
reliable best of all you can deposit and
withdraw your cash whenever you want
download the draftking sportsbook app
right now use promo code kats bet just
five dollars on college football and get
200 in free bets instantly that's code
kats only at draftkingsportsbook now
time for the boring part 21 they're pl
older in most eligible states but age
varies by jurisdiction eligibility
restrictions apply see draftkings.com
sportsbook for terms and resources
gambling problem cool call 100 gambler
in tennessee call or text the tennessee
red line at 1-800-889-9789
in new york call 8778 hope ny or text
hope ny four six seven three six nine
one per new customer minimum five dollar
wager 200 issued as eight 25 free bads
that's draftkings
promo code k-a-t-s
oh right well i watched a little bit of
a light year just to put it on buzz
terrible the one yeah terrible because
my son goes that one that's what he says
whenever one comes you wasted your money
you waste your money no no it was
streaming right it's on disney plus
yeah we didn't go so uh i went and uh or
i i was there and i watched it in about
two three scenes and he checked out and
i was like yeah i get i'm kind of into
it but like as an adult but i just
bounced out of it no it's boring like
the whole story line is boring i don't
know you watched it
no uh i saw the guy i know no no no no
no no they took tim allen out of it i'm
out
i'm out so captain america's buzz
lightyear now and you two are okay with
us you're the bro listen
okay first of all let me explain this to
him right now let me explain this
toy story
the character of toy story
tim allen is the toy now i get it this
movie is the order it's about the real
buzz lightyear now that is
compartmentalized
right i'm just saying if you're going to
get it right but that voice
this is like this [ __ ] doesn't
know the difference between matrix power
and jedi power i don't want to start
with him he thinks the matrix and the
jedi is the same [ __ ] so i'm out on his
[ __ ] nick get me off him and [ __ ] quick
they don't know all right they don't
know dude i did a joke about counter
reeves and if i had those powers then he
was like you know actually uh the
difference is no you because you went
like this because you went like this you
were like as if neo okay you know what
let's let's see what the [ __ ] can we see
cute mark already
can't even hear of course nick's never
ready
it's like it's like it's like nick comes
in at night and messes with all the [ __ ]
someone wants the camera i don't touch
it and he fixes the difference ready it
works and then we talk more and then
yeah that's not right yeah it was ready
to go and now it's not
yes or someone's sabotaging it i think
that the cleaning crew comes in me the
cleaning crew comes in and they mess
with the with the with the things that
guy he he didn't put oh that guy no it's
definitely all right we'll figure it out
that's right you got this nick has to
wear clocks he's going to walk over here
hey nick he has to it's his thing i
would rather you [ __ ] up the audio than
wear crocs with jeans
i'm doing folks oh yeah he has on crocs
with jeans are you living in your car i
feel sick again yeah that's i moved here
yeah he lived in this car for a second
wow yeah hot [ __ ]
that's when he had a real bad gambling
issue
rich white's unite ironically not
gambling when i was living in my car
yeah oh that's a let me see that one
i've had this for a while it's nice and
shiny there we go nothing changed all
right let's do it okay
what's up guys i'm tyler i'm 18 from
detroit got the bait club for you guys
um if you're born with action figure
hands
uh stuck in the same position forever um
what position would you put your hands
in
uh thanks guys
buzz buzz
soar
not bad yeah uh what a good question
especially what we were talking about
yeah we're talking about we know this we
know erickson no you're [ __ ] happy
remember remember mr i want my legs
instead of my arms oh yeah yeah i still
believe that hold on
yeah you guys are out of your face i
guess you gotta like do you want it to
be like where you can always still grab
your dick
dude come on you know you you get others
to do that you you you forgo this grip
and you just yeah but you can still get
your like dude you want more of like a
you can get a good handle with a spoon
on the end and you can still eat doing
what this guy wants
just this
or like am i just hugs there's only one
answer to this and it's this this
you want this oh so you can grab that
grab certain things and still kind of
manipulate it
what can you grab okay okay wait what
could you this is gonna be you with your
phone you know you can't talk to your
kid anymore because you can't all right
check it out
first of all i'm there present with my
kid okay he's gone right now
how are you gonna facetime them you go
like this your fingers are bending yeah
they're not dude yeah they can't move
anything you can't see we can't hold
this yeah
let's see
no no no no no
oh what are you one of those machines it
looks like it looks on it hooks on dude
and then i still drink my coffee check
it out
so you want to be like another [ __ ] this
this so you want to be this i i it's got
to be somewhere i like thumbs up your
mouth is no no i like it to be like i
wanted to be like that i want to be like
you can still eat a hoagie that way
because you can get your phone look at
that
we haven't heard brendan brandon would
just be this
the whole time just
he couldn't move his arms ever
no it's only this
this
you could go like this that's all you're
like jack's all bro
and me and him have the exact same body
so that's cool uh anyways that's what i
would have picked the same as chris
cause i had the action figure it was
just this and you could pick up a two by
four yeah yeah yeah yeah okay good yeah
because yeah you need to pick up the two
by your hands
kingston crew
what up this is uh cellmate three seven
seven four seven seven nine eight well
he's like hey just taking a break from
shooting intervention real quick king of
this thing
hold on uh he's a convict
i think he's joking okay
coming at you hot front now i'm just
[ __ ] with you dude i'm [ __ ]
i know you were gonna climb me for it uh
anywho uh no i'm just actually chilling
here in my beautiful hometown of port
lincoln
um
and just had a quick
[ __ ] debate club for you
uh because we're one of the biggest
importers exporter like grain and tuner
and [ __ ] uh yeah have a good gaze
it's silos boats beautiful where
whatever
ah
would you rather work on land or at sea
um
[Music]
if he has like cancer i think that was
like a piercer maybe had like a thing
inserted i don't know oh that's right
weird little bump
portland port lincoln
australia oh that was portland he's just
doing like that johnny depp accident no
no no no no no no no no no no yeah what
and what prison would we think he's in
that he's got a cell phone that he could
just do a video
dudes i think they have
but that's my question how do they get
cell phones come on deal with that
no i don't know you never seen 60 days
in no through the ass bubba
i really like how brendan laughed at you
like
you idiot
dude
sneaking [ __ ] into the prisons it's as
old as time i know that but do they
check their anus no no no no they don't
not if you get up there all the time
maybe it's like a spot check so you take
somebody comes in what they do too is
drones they'll drone it over or they'll
have someone at the uh in the yard and
they'll throw it over the gate or the
majority
the majority comes from the security
guards they pay them big buckaroos but
how do they get the money to pay them
the outside family pays this cur
security guard and they smuggle it in
and then and then so they just hook into
the internet or i guess they have self
serve wow
that's [ __ ] insane wow dude
technology keeps changing so much these
prisoners are gonna be out of there in
no time they're gonna be setting up
holograms and they're just gonna be
[ __ ] gone and they've got followings
on tick tocks when they get out
following famous bro oh yeah oh my god
people are monetizing from prison yeah
welcome it's kind of like prison tick
tock this is a stage
the lives of incarcerated people that
were once hidden are now going viral
thanks to the younger generation no it's
never hidden i'm so hyped up about them
they get to see what it's like behind
the wall it's like a whole other world
kevin smith is one of dozens of people
who have posted their prison experiences
on the platform
something to do we're seeing the daily
meals that was a good trade that i
posted the trays that are in there that
are so gross like it'll run away from
you before you eat it well don't commit
a crime more time
and right
it just feels bad for them like heating
up hot water
i mean i'm with you on that 100 percent
but at the same time i'm like okay you
believe this bread there's mold on it
bro you killed seven people still
okay uh i don't know how to feel mind
blowing that there's tick tock in prison
yeah isn't it cool
bro
oh i like the ones where the you know
what i'm with you it's making me feel
like do i need to like get off tick tock
yeah
oh you're viewing the wrong way or you
guys need to step your game up daddy
our resident sales person of course yes
yeah dude my favorites on there is when
they have an inmate for whatever reason
[ __ ] up or stole and they trained him
like a dog you haven't seen this like
came around the [ __ ] cell thing yeah
a guy oh yeah dude it's wild in there
well why did they do that because he
stole something he's just you know he
holds people's pockets and sucks the
homies off
dude are you guys from 1994 no i just
don't am am i the only one with this
stuff
dude it's like shawl shank
but
without morgan freeman there's no red
helping you out it's just a nightmare so
they get busy living with the tick tock
whoa dude that's mine get busy living or
get out so this guy's saying work at
land or sea
so i i pick land dude this is in prison
i don't want to be [ __ ] bouncing
around on a [ __ ] boat
not taking a real shower well your navy
hat would beg the differ yeah
he just said beg the differ i know i'm
just i just come on it's better to
differ
and captain america has super powers no
he doesn't he's on steroids that's a
superpower
okay then i'm captain america
[Laughter]
hey guys give me a shield let's see if
it fires back he has better okay okay i
can get her
you're low more steroids are not the
same as
you know
do you see how he looked before he took
the steroids he was like
you know normal soldier he was like
what's his name junior [ __ ] he was puny
and then he took the thing and he turned
out you know what i mean
thank you
i miss myself
that is a mouthful um i love you guys
i'm a patreon and i have a quick
question for you what do you do if your
husband doesn't make you laugh
it's always been an issue and kill him
really leave that [ __ ]
he's like
so high up there for me i watch you guys
like
um so
and
he's he's not funny
but anyways i feel like it's starting to
get to us because both of us are just so
different and when we say a joke it
doesn't deliver the way that we want it
to to each other so now you feel like
we're not very seen
um i know the real problem and yeah i
think it's starting to get to us poison
them um what can we do to fix that is
there any way to fix that is it
changeable
um or
is it just how it's going to be for the
rest of our life
all right thanks guys and i love you all
bye turn on an adam sandler movie no no
don't know why this [ __ ] exists no no no
no no no no no no no the problem is she
watches this show okay right and she's
like oh
you could be funny and handsome
you know what i'm saying she's looking
like oh man she's like eric he's all
about you can be cute tall
manly and be funny so the problem is i
need to see what her husband looks like
because i think that's the real issue
but also it's not just his sense of
humor she's probably like oh
yeah but also you you knew this going
that's what you signed up or or or was
he kind of funny when you were dating
and you've taken the light from it oh
that's a really good there's that it
does happen where she just took sucked
like a vampire sucked all the life out
of my man seems like a tough crowd too
like her husband is talking and she's
all giving him the light
she's a tough crowd she just wants to
laugh she wants to laugh if you want to
laugh you're not a tough crowd maybe
he's just boring and [ __ ] but here's the
thing you find the intricacies and the
funny stuff like if you're not going to
laugh with him laugh at him sorry yeah
bro it's not no i'm with you it's not
there that's why she's talking like this
she's like yeah it's just not he's just
not funny he's obviously gonna see this
and be like what the [ __ ] but also if
you he's not because he's boring if
you're funny you can figure out a way
that somebody else is funny and laugh at
them no perfect she's got to say
you disagree with that because she's
because what i'm saying
she she probably lives in a small place
where she from did she say where she was
from i don't think she's turned some
small place and she thinks like oh this
is the funniest guy in town and then she
turns on her thing and she's like oh
look at these guys oh she might be right
she's from bronx new york that's cool um
no she's definitely not no but also it
could be they're just growing like it
happens man like maybe
10 years ago and you just grow apart how
about this let's help the guy because
he's probably watching too he's probably
wants to like kill himself because he's
just like you know what i mean it's a
terrible you know what i mean his wife
is well he's like my side piece finds me
hilarious
how about that [ __ ]
you know who thinks i'm funny your
sister
well your mom thinks i'm hilarious
what do you got
what's up andrew
how's it going boys hello what's up dog
hi
oh you know just
out here looking for love oh yeah let us
help you out man all right well uh so we
got a debate club which is the worst way
to go out because these two last ones
have happened to me recently
your girl leaves you for her step
brother
or
her crazy ex shows up and attacks you
with a hammer okay the first one is uh
better because you don't get to get hit
by a hammer and then also that has
nothing to do with you dude if she's
gonna go out with your f with her step
brother
she's got issues that have nothing to do
with you yeah oh and they now have a
baby
okay well wow oh boy that's not illegal
because it is frowned upon in society
now as the guy that attacked you with
the hammer did the church the girl oh oh
the girl attacked you with the hammer
no no no it's her ex oh i've got her axe
attacked with a hammer but did you stay
with the girl and did you [ __ ] them uh i
mean for the night just so she could
take care of me then i had to get out of
there i have another graphic image we're
going to bring up okay
here's
he hit you in the eye with the hammer
dude
and then
yeah obviously and where's the guy
uh right now we're building the case you
know trying to do some police work show
them the pick
wow dude i did they didn't do much right
away did he now did he just jump like
blindside you and hit you in the face or
what's going on i was
i was upstairs in the apartment and he
slammed on the door and he kind of
banged the door down just came upstairs
and that was and he smashed up my
windows in my car too jesus christ
bigger dude or what are we talking about
here
a little bigger i tried to hit him with
that hard scarf but wasn't having it
yeah
when did this happen
about three weeks ago oh
wow you've healed up good my man i know
i gotta i got a little bit of the blood
eye still but that's not bad [ __ ] you
heal up fast like wolverine your teeth
that's [ __ ] thank god huh
i know i couldn't lose those babies yeah
and and what the cra what'd your girl
say about this she's like i'm sorry he's
crazy or pretty much
yeah well he is crazy she's still with
him but she went to the cops with me so
i guess she's on my side and you still
talk to her
try not to i think you know maybe we
don't need to be involved each other
[Laughter]
i would have to see how hot she is
no dude
there's no hotness level i'd rather
sleep
least bad
what's that
the step brother's least bad that's what
you're saying yeah yeah pretty easy i'm
curious about the step brother when when
did your ex and the step brother
when when did they become
like if they're like 22 and their
parents married it's a little yeah if
they grew up since they're like two
that's strange yeah
okay oh damn it see now you guys aren't
going to be on my side then no they were
pretty older when it happened but oh no
we're still on your side
yeah we're going to decide regardless as
long as this picture is up on the screen
i'm on your side
you know what i mean
thank you now i hate them do you know
yeah i hate them too well where are you
located maybe we can uh try and give
your instagram maybe we can have some
girls hit you up who won't have the guys
about two hours north of sacramento
and what's your instagram
uh it's uh andrew stone with two um
two underscores in front of it
underscore underscore andrews i mean
maybe i could connect you with a jiu
jitsu gym to defend yourself or some
[ __ ]
well i mean stop just like like my
grandma keeps sending me weapons from
amazon wow
that's dope though that sounds like a
[ __ ] lifetime movie yeah
my grandma keeps sending me weapons from
amazon but they're like old-school
weapons it's like uh you know an axe
yeah like one's across i got a billy
club and a stun gun
your grandma's a little late bro
it sounds like a 1950s english police
officer yes sir
the guy was waiting for you
the guy was just jealous is that yeah
what set this off yeah what happened
here he got he got word that her friend
took her home from the bar
told her that i was coming over so he
got words bad friend
bad friend yeah and then
yeah so he came over with said hammer
wow
well glad you're okay yeah and how long
have you been dating this chick
uh we did it for about a year okay
that's a long time so you were with her
for a year and then finally you guys
broke up and then you were still trying
to smash
yep and she was with but she was with me
but she was with the other guy
right careful with you so you were
trying to like you got it you were
trying to get her oh
so you're kind of nah [ __ ] that yeah
you don't get hit with a hat you can't
attack somebody with a hammer i get it
but at the same time it's like you had
your shot bro and she's mine now and he
hammered you you're dancing with the
devil bro yeah you're dancing with the
devil yeah dance with a hammer
that's a scary devil well thanks man
that was super depressing
we're sorry brother yeah hopefully that
doesn't happen again this is a success
story you came out alive that's good i
mean you could have died bro you know
but he didn't go to jail instantly every
week big fans you didn't call the cops
right away anyway what's three weeks
from now three weeks from now he's
facetime is from prison
he's like hey man so my grandma actually
sent me a real weapon i killed him he's
huge
yeah he's big on tick tock here's my uh
soup that i like to make
here's my here's the hammer i use i
brought it into my anus well thanks
andrew good luck brother sorry all right
thanks boys big fans love you guys later
brother yeah
the only thing there is so it was the
dude's girlfriend really that girl sucks
yeah that girl sucks
yeah but you did sleep with a guy's
girlfriend yeah they also hammer's
insane though hammered those guys on top
you know who's got to feel bad is like
the friends this guy who was just trying
to start [ __ ] people just trying to
start [ __ ] and then so look what they
cause i know yeah mind your [ __ ]
business this is joseph what's up
joseph
what's going on brendan good to see you
guys good to see you brother how you
doing man i forgot it was live hi
yeah this is crazy that this is live i'm
doing good
where are you going from now on
i'm in valdosta georgia but i'm from
tallahassee florida
nice brother
are you with that uh that top on you're
like an exterminator what what's going
on here
uh no i'm actually a
i'm a superintendent for a building
contractor i build a bunch of houses
florida in georgia
and uh yeah so that's that's where i'm
at right now i'm at a construction site
oh wow got my amigos back here framing
nice yeah kind of just sitting in the
truck kind of have the easy job um
that's cool brother what's going on man
how can we help you you're king in the
sting or king understand it for us
uh you got you have an animal that's
crazy so i actually happen to have
um
two animals oh sick
so i found these little guys yesterday
say hi
in a pile of trusses
um on my job site and the crane was
about to lift the trusses on the house
so they were going to get crushed oh wow
so
what's crazy is like right before that i
found like a
nest of baby squirrels i've never seen
it before
and i put the baby squirrel somewhere
that was that i thought was safe
and i came back like 20 30 minutes later
in a [ __ ] swarm of ants it devoured
oh my god oh [ __ ] shoot me out scoot me
until i like 10 minutes later i find
these little
little bundles of joy right here and
i couldn't um
i couldn't bring it upon myself to you
know leave them so the debate club is
do you do what i do and hide them in
your work truck i hope your boss doesn't
find them and [ __ ] bottle feed them
back to safety or do you uh
do you let mother nature sort it out and
kind of leave them somewhere you think
it's safe i don't know i don't i haven't
found a shelter for them yet so i don't
know what to do with them and i can't
keep them in the house so
they're just kind of chilling with me
all day for now that's kind of cool man
god bless you also if you left them you
know they don't have a mama so there's
no milk or nothing man so they're going
to die for sure
yeah or if she found them that she could
reject him you know what i mean so yeah
i just figured i would take him yeah he
said rejected you know the mother yeah
sometimes the mother rejects the thing
once they've been touched by human hands
the mother well rejected i'm still
tripping on the answer that you know it
just lets me know what kind of answer
you
ants were the size of like dogs like
that size they'd be running they'd be
running [ __ ] you never you never move
any kind of nest man if you move a nest
that nest is [ __ ] dude i've seen honey
i shrunk the kids
i uh
but look that's your reference for name
another ant movie where humans are tiny
oh my god all right so uh yeah i think
you're doing the right thing dude i mean
you know you can't keep them in your
house for whatever reason which you know
we respect but like you know you you
have them all day and you're doing your
thing you know you're hiding from your
boss which i i don't know if you need to
hide them from your ball yeah yeah tell
your boss to be cool but also why can't
you keep them at your house i think you
have two cats now it's what's the
tissues
yeah
you might be right eric i might have two
cats yeah so i have a
yeah
okay by the way this one is a little i
don't know if you can see her eyes
she's a little crossed out i don't think
you can see
dope you got to take you got to go get
shots and stuff for those cats man you
got to take them to the go to the vet
get them checked out you know what i'm
saying you have two cats here
are you married are you married
i i just got engaged two weeks ago
actually so does she know about these
cats yet so here's what you do
yeah you go through the bottle you said
hey engagement present two cats then you
look at your hero
so the cats enter her yeah
dude we both just kind of started a new
job like just to have a dog also let her
know hey look how much i like [ __ ]
[Laughter]
thank you for being a friend
i mean i'll just leave them in your car
man let them grow up can we name them
right now do you name them
yep oh my god please please i don't have
any names
wait it's one boy one girl yeah this is
the girl she's kind of like a little
cheetah prince yeah they're sweet
looking the boy if i wasn't allergic to
cats i'd take it theo should be the boy
dude
you can have him where's he can have him
no name him theo
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
he's so different with some cats they
are cats um cats
cats
cats um cats in the wild dude
legit you found those in the wild
wow straight up those are cute as [ __ ]
they are cute yeah little they are they
can get their shots keep them and then
[ __ ] you know if it works it works oh
bro flip them
flip them make some money
i say name that guy one theater when we
come up with the name for the girl all
right so theo and what
theo and
daddy buddy
theo brenda
theo and brenda yeah brenda yeah there
you go okay
theo and brenda i love that brenda
sounds like my lesbian daughter who
plays softball
all right well thank you
appreciate you thanks brother thanks for
saving those cats man that's really cool
yeah you got two cats now tell your lady
i appreciate it love you guys take care
take care brother all right speaking of
brenda we've got another debate club
he's still on and now it's just awkward
we've already said goodbye if you don't
address him no one knows what if he just
starts being the show i love you guys
he's like [ __ ] god
said get off
we see him he just throws him out the
window
he takes him by the scrub
yeah it goes to the passenger seat he
goes here's your cat's back and it's
just somebody's cast
somebody's sitting there here's the next
debate club
see how stupid you know this one's not
good
what's up king of the steam crew
i got a quick suck it or [ __ ] it for
y'all
that's a new one which one of your
co-stars or even yourself
would you smash if you were a girl bro
i already rendered the pictures and all
that [ __ ] i'm gonna send them over
and y'all let me know y'all looking
pretty good
i don't like this cause he used the very
best pictures
gang gang buzz buzz this is not good
what he did
okay i don't think i saw it yeah i
haven't seen it all right it's this is
chicks all i'm saying is this theo
whoo you got that ass steel's a bad
[ __ ]
that's just [ __ ] up
doesn't look like me well that's just
chinese
um
[Music]
i think that's good no why not are you
kidding me
that's brenda
[Applause]
tell yeah well that doesn't look like
the [ __ ] woman from walking dead
what's the in the first dude you look
like bruce wilson's daughter yeah rumor
um i uh who's that that's who's that
that's me oh that's you
okay nick okay i think i think it's
weird theo if i'm gonna be honest but
the best one you know what i mean
i mean i look pretty hot
this is the best one brendan it's not
the best one
like
i'm maya
[Applause]
but that person is so annoying whoever
that is
that's your auntie right there what are
you talking about
she's she thinks she's really funny yeah
yeah
okay nick you're fired you are
you're gonna pick the better picture
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
this one is
that's kayla harrison that is
[Laughter]
all right mark that's an actual picture
why are you dressing like that
he did it for this
[Laughter]
isn't that what you guys did yeah let's
check out check out brendan's really
rethinking the whole relationship right
now
there's gonna be a meeting after this
podcast i mean it's insane it's in this
thick boy studios bathroom yeah
holy [ __ ]
wow
all right
outraged by my picture your [ __ ] is
hilarious there's there's better
pictures of me that he could have used
i mean
that was so funny man
what a great [ __ ] what was that
sucker [ __ ] he [ __ ] you up bro
what's up guys this is preston from
flying v farms in tulsa oklahoma
kelly thank you guys for keeping the
show going theo brendan man you guys
started it you're great chris eric uh
man the four of you guys are dynamic
together i love watching the show now
anyway y'all can rip my drip on this
heisenberg hitter but the real reason i
called
was
getting high on your own supply king it
or sting it
i king it that's real that's that real
sticky icky dude
that's that purple dream that's that
[ __ ] uh
chocolate tie dude
are these still weeds i heard them in
rap songs in the 90s i was about to say
like what are you doing you know
hey you know what are you doing right
now sticky green you sound like him
talking about martial i was just gonna
say you sound like me talking about
superhero i'm admitting i don't know
about weed
i've never done any weeds dude sticky
icky sticky green purple purple purple
haze
ooh
chocolate tie
that's all i know i don't know i mean
price shouldn't get high on your own
supply it's less than number one have
you ever seen [ __ ] don't get your
boys
yeah dude if you do your high if you get
high on your own supplies get your your
wig pusher you get your [ __ ] pushed in
uh i don't think anyone [ __ ] you
oh you get your [ __ ] pushed
dude every time i do that i feel like
macho man randy savage and not the guy
from training today
training day oh where ethan hawson down
the table
oh i'm thinking
i'm thinking of uh what was the movie
with uh james
edwards almost uh uh standing in the
liver no no no it was the prison movie
american meme yeah yeah oh you know he
hasn't been the same since that they
were they were after him because of that
movie he would probably the mexican
mafia yeah portraying him like that yeah
man they were like yeah you don't make a
movie like that yeah
speaking of macho man because it was a
lot of sex in that movie this sorry this
went crazy viral last week this macho
man talking about crying he was my
favorite of all time okay your
your middle name is macho
but uh
i'm gonna take it never cry you ever had
the macho man ever crying oh yeah really
uh-huh two keeper macho men to show
every emotion available right there you
know because i've cried a thousand times
i'm gonna cry some more but
i've soared with the eagles and i've
slithered with the snakes and i've been
everywhere in between and i'm gonna tell
you something right now the problem
guarantee in life and that there are no
guarantees yeah and
i understand this
nobody likes a quitter nobody said life
was easy so if you get knocked down take
the standing eight count get back up and
fight again and you're a macho maniac
dig it
dig it
is that is that outfit gucci that thing
was lit it's a good promo that's so
weird he's the best podcast [ __ ] two
weeks ago i was like how much would he
be in a viral clip you said that went
viral yeah it was it was trending on
twitter like macho man talking about
that's so weird i wonder if i [ __ ]
subconsciously you know you know what's
weird is uh when i would get hurt as a
kid i would say
out loud to go macho man macho man
thanks for waiting kelly we got you on
now
oh hello what's up girl
hi how are you guys good how are you
love the nose piercings good
thank you eric are you there yes ma'am
hello i got a king interesting hello hi
eric hi
i got a king interesting for you guys
uh throwing yourself a birthday party um
uh and why don't you give us background
why that happened because also give
yourself so um
i'm turning 30 next month and i decided
to throw myself a party
i'm slightly regretting it but it's
already too late it's a lot of work um
but so far a lot of people are excited
yeah i don't mind it you're taking the
reins it's just a lot of work and it's
yeah my
once i told my mom she kind of took over
so i'm not that bad about it but now do
you have to pay for all of it
no my mom paid for the place that um
we're renting out and she's cooking all
the food oh you're good so i just have
to show up
and she said so bad sorry she sent in
another king and her singing as well and
i would say part of the
it was about um you just broke off your
engagement so co-parenting your your dog
so would you say your your birthday
party yeah yeah get back on the horse
and have you still thought oh well then
yeah then that's a little bit more
yeah my fiance left me um and so i was
wondering what to do like do we share
custody of our dog because we got her
together and
i would never you know give her up
i'm sorry to hear that but no you don't
don't share custody no no it's and then
you gotta you gotta see him all the time
and you know can you get paid well i
actually work with him so i have to see
him every day
yeah he delivers mail time it's all good
he delivers mail yeah
yeah that's how we met
what kind of dog is it
a golden doodle and my brother has one
of those they're not cheap
she's a black golden doodle named
wednesday how about we just get you a
new dog
we know a guy who's a little girl no get
him a new dog
i'm a problem solver man no that's not
the salt the solution it is this
[ __ ] left her he don't get the
dog too [ __ ] him yeah well we'll see in
court yeah that's true you know what i'm
saying yeah he's done enough damage yeah
and like you know by the way it's like
why did you i didn't like this you know
what i mean you did the third you did
you you knew you were turning you were
turning 30 and are you do you do you
feel anything about like none of your
friends wanted to do this or are you not
close with your friends or like how does
this make you know
no i have really good friends um it was
just like i don't know i've never been
big on my birthday and you know when
you're younger your mom or your parents
usually throw you a party when you're a
kid and then as you get older you know a
friend or a family member again but i
was just like you know what i'm just
gonna take the reins and do it myself i
don't have a problem with it yeah yeah
you're good i don't have a problem with
it and you're not paying for it so
that's cool i mean it's a little
annoying if you have to [ __ ] uh
plan it which just seems like you did in
the beginning then your mom kind of took
the reigns over don't cover the middle
yeah
um
but yeah it's good you're good you're
you're you're you're you're you're
as long as she didn't like surprise
herself you gotta be weird
party yeah
no no what it is is she's waiting at the
party by herself and invites all her
friends to come at the same time and
she's gonna open the door and she goes
surprise it's my birthday
i
my favorite cake you ordered it um but i
think the bigger issue is the dog and
homeboy like you guys got to figure that
out def you don't you don't want to do
that i think eric yeah
are you having trouble seeing him at
work is it like you know it's like is he
cool he's not cool
they were engaged i'm saying is he being
cool at work for [ __ ] sake oh that's
different yeah we don't really
talk um we kind of were trying to work
things out and it seemed to have fallen
through again so now why did he lean it
is what it is what's it stem from why do
you leave
um
you'd have to ask differences yeah just
difference i get it creative differences
when's your when's your birthday i mean
what like
males are different differences
all right we'll shout you out on the
free show too
yeah we'll give you a shout out for sure
from us for you for your birthday
oh yeah thank you i was down to buy our
dog
i mean i my dog needs a friend so i
always take it
well i'll send a pit bull wait
yeah
you set yourself up
well thank you well good luck have a
great birthday i want to feel any type
of way about it yeah good luck yeah
thank you i appreciate it great seeing
you guys tell that guy we said he sucks
get her off the screen we don't know who
that is
um
she seems like a real what's going on
boys it's josh from up here in oregon i
got a king interesting for you guys
today
powerlifting at 68 years old
my dad's been competing in powerlifting
since his early 20s when powerlifting
became a sport
and i just went to a meet with him the
other day and he uh broke a world record
and bench press at just over 400 pounds
and broke a world record and dead lift
at just over 600 pounds god damn it it's
uh a little bit scary as a son watching
him compete at this age because you know
i wish he would just kind of retire and
kick back but the guy's doing what he
loves and i love watching him do what he
loves so
just wanted to see what you guys thought
about powerlifting as a senior citizen
king of this thing
what them cast do baby
[Applause]
what
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh he could have done more
right yeah easily well he's got to get
it over his head first right no that's
the death this dog oh that's it stick to
superheroes that would have been awesome
if you just
what did you see how he like kind of be
the one
he kind of almost passed out right there
especially for his age it's pretty
insane
remember remember when i did 600 oh yeah
i mean most people don't even understand
how heavy 600 pounds is you know it
feels like your spine's going to rip out
i didn't think i didn't i could feel
like the like my my spinal
yeah and then i did it and i was like oh
that's cool for the gram and then dude
i couldn't i couldn't drive home really
no no my back's seized up i had to pull
over like stretch actually i was [ __ ]
for like a month yeah yeah well i mean i
was like oh that's the real issue is
what we're talking about here is this
guy is like i could tell that he like
loves his dad i can tell they have a
great relationship and he's just saying
like hey it's like he wants his dad to
just slow down and just be an old man
nah [ __ ] that you know
he's going out he's like patrick swayze
and [ __ ] point break he's like dude
i'll see you uh you know he goes and
does the [ __ ] uh the last wave and
yeah yeah i live my life
okay so debate club do you want your dad
to like
like go out like on a big wave or like
just pass out from lifting and they'd
never wake up which one
i wanted to go out like i don't want to
just sit in a [ __ ] rocking chair and
pat like you know decay away like do
your thing i'd rather go [ __ ] dead
lifting 700 pounds but everyone retires
you know
yeah but
the question is
do you want you do you want to selfishly
want to see your parent just kind of
chill so you can have them around longer
or do you want your parent to go out
doing what they love doing what they
love do whatever the [ __ ] you want
yeah i don't know i think your dad's
just show running and he's just like
and action
i don't think um
i don't think uh i don't know man i
don't know to me nothing's more
important than family so ah
i can't imagine doing that [ __ ] it's
like this is an easy one it's not like
he's a navy that's senior that's true
he's not i thought he's going to iraq
like man that's getting really stressful
he's 65. you're still going on
blackwater
he's told us that you had to pull you're
a young man and you had to pull over
because your back was [ __ ] we're
talking about a 68 year old man lifting
600 pounds and he almost passed out
right there
but he's okay
well still i mean the next time he might
and it's healthy to work out it's better
than just working out
no for him to get there he's doing sets
every day
all week months like that's okay but
that's the difference between say
training to be a ufc fighter but
actually being in the ring you can end
up killing yourself i agree yeah you
know what i mean you just work out yeah
he likes to compete he's got that dog
that's what i'm saying yeah i'm kind of
torn between it because i totally get it
but like look my my parents moved to
spain and when they left i thought oh i
i it could be a possibility i never see
them again but i was like
they this is what they wanted to do yeah
you know what i mean it's like she did
she always wanted to do this and i was
like all right i support you go do your
thing i mean no one can speak better on
this mark's dad passed away doing what
he loves literally
doing doing a triathlon uh yeah uh
yeah he was he was an open water swimmer
and he got he used to be like a
record-holding um swimmer at his youth
he would
uh after high school he got into open
water and so there's a lot of courses in
the bay area like
different paths across the bay that he
was like the first person to do
and
got away from it got overweight in his
forties and then in his fifties he like
got back into it i love him he's in
really good shape and he would do these
bridge swims and he was uh
doing a swim under the
brooklyn bridge to raise charity to
raise money for this um school that my
little brother was helping start in
africa and during the swim he had a
heart attack that could have happened
any time right like because you build up
plaque in your you know you get heart
disease but yes it is a silver lining on
like
i've never seen my dad happier right in
his final years because when you're not
doing what you love you're miserable and
depressed and suicidal you know so
and that guy also looks like he was even
though he was about to pass out his form
did look really good hell yeah and you
don't want to be old and like not be
able to stand up so when i see strong
old people it's like yeah your quality
of life is better yeah it had the legs
of moana like they were [ __ ] jacked
yeah that was good dude okay well then
yeah i think it's okay i mean maybe the
guy's a little worried that he it's a
lot of weight for a [ __ ] you know for
an old guy yeah i just think about my
dad but that guy's also i just look at
him price 300 some pounds like that's
not that crazy
that's not that crazy it just makes me
laugh thinking a bill thinking of bill
trying to dead lift your dad power lifts
still he's pretty easy yeah he worked
out all the time yeah non-stop uh you
guys got anything easier i'm not gonna
tell him to stop and get a [ __ ]
booster just coffee man coffee and chill
with my kid yeah well i mean he'll be
out but i'll when i'm all over the
coffee and trying to call my kids
whatever you understand where we can do
when we're grandpa's yeah you got any
hobbies planned
[ __ ]
i'm gonna do surround drink i'll
probably drink and like yell at the
script i'll tell you this much if i'm
still doing podcasts [ __ ] shoot me in
the head oh i'm doing podcasts for sure
i'm being wild
because old guys have a free pass yeah
you're going to be in congratulations
like this
[Music]
you'll be selling your merch here's my
merch
[ __ ]
still podcast he's 55 years old
yeah 60 years from now that'd be episode
3000. wow you still want to do
like stand up and [ __ ] when you're how
do you know you know yeah you still want
to just stand like when you dude i was
thinking about [ __ ]
after this tour like when do i want to
do another one am i going to another one
really you just started scott just got
back into it yeah i know but it's
difficult
it's different now i don't want to be
away from my family man i don't want to
be able to bring him
i know i know i know but yeah but that's
not always going to be the case and
you're in theaters
yeah
yeah maybe i could do one show on a
saturday and fly that's what i'm yeah
yeah vegas residency
yeah yeah yeah you could do that that's
what the big boys do
congratulations at the mirage
that's my only goal is to get the
theater so i can just do one night
before my son gets into sports so i
don't miss any games
yeah otherwise i'm only touring in the
off season what do you mean off season
your kid's going to play season i know
but
i have a feeling he's going to want to
do like all you know it's like you have
the football season
you have the basketball track season and
then you have the other you know i don't
i'm missing basketball
next thing kid's not making in
basketball you feel me you don't know
that i know that yeah
what up king sting wing and sing got a
king or stinging for you here uh mainly
directed towards chris because he always
says that your hair hair should be
longer than your beard hair
uh well when you're balding at 27 i
would say that it's probably a must huh
i mean i'd look like a [ __ ] baby so
uh yeah king or sing it bald with beard
you have to no
gang gang
buzz buzz
sore and
[Music]
i think dope i think that if you're
completely bald like that you can have
some facial hair you have to yeah i'm
with them you look like a giant creepy
baby yeah but if you have a little bit
of hair on your head and then longer
beard then i don't agree with that dude
i like when it's completely bald and
then just big ass beard that's a style
uh
i don't know hey fletcher i think you
should have uh longer hair hair than
beard hair all the way i i can't stand
people holding on for dear life that's
what you're talking about yeah they got
this little [ __ ] [ __ ] up top yeah
get rid of that it's upside down yeah
just get rid of it
it's upside down and i don't think that
and i don't stand for it i think that
you should trim up the beard a little
bit more but also yeah the people that
hold on to it you're fighting this fight
and you're not winning you're down 10a
bubba in the rounds it's not good yeah
but when you have a billion dollars in
the bank you could
you know sometimes he has hair sometimes
even he painted it one time looked like
a [ __ ] steelers helmet you know that
i know it's just stars they're just like
us
and that's it you'll wear wig all right
well thanks guys we appreciate you the
support on patreon we love you guys yes
patreon we see in dallas and wichita and
atlanta that's right huh
[Music]
dc yep and i'm in appleton wisconsin
september 8th through the 10th and then
ontario improv is september i think 15th
to 17th and then i end september's tour
in boston laugh boston get you some i
think that's the 29th through october
first comedy story la jolla september
9th through the 11th the improv in
milwaukee 15-17 skank skankfest 14th
through 16th and calusa casino october
28th love you guys
[Music]
[Music]
and the sting and the wing